improve your Python and Pie game skills
by building the classic pong game but
with some new features Rohan created
this course and it's a great project for
beginners you will learn how Pi game can
be leveraged to create engaging games
with Unique Mechanics let's get started
welcome to the Spy game ponkos this is
where we modify the traditional pong
game by adding in multiple new features
such as increasing the movement speed at
times all the way up to cloning the
objects to confuse the opponent I am a
content creator at snds we make videos
about machine learning data science and
some general programming videos in
Python and pygame like this now I do
want to mention that this course is for
those who have intermediate knowledge of
code so if you're able to understand the
looping structures such as a y Loop and
the for Loop and if you can understand
the conditional statements such as the
if alif and else then you should be good
to watch this video but with that said
if you're a complete beginner then you
can still watch this video and see what
you can write out of it now I will be
using visual studio code as my code
editor also make sure to install the pi
game audio onto your computer I'm not
going to go onto that because there's
just kind of tutorials out there on how
to install the buy game module so I'm
just going to presume that you already
have it installed now with all that said
let's get into the video
let's take a quick minute to tell you
what Wayne will be covering in this
course we will start with going by
building the metrics of the original on
game where we first create a window and
then draw the required objects that is
the ball and the paddles and then we
will Define the movements for these and
then the collisions such as the ball
colliding with boundaries or the ball
colliding with the paddles after this we
will be building our first kind of new
element which I'm going to name this as
creative angles you will get to know
about this in detail when you get to
that part of the video then we will be
creating two comprehensive brand new
elements which I'm going to refer to as
Gadget pair 1 and Gadget pair two the
first pair will comprise of the smashed
element which will smash the ball back
onto the opponent and the Flash element
which will teleport the paddle up or
down to a specific distance and the
second pair will comprise of the ball
cloning and the paddle cloning which as
the name suggests or creates a throne of
the respective and then finally we will
be adding in the scoreboard on the
window followed by the end screen or the
winning screen
all right let's start with importing Pi
game first import buy game and then I'm
just going to go ahead and type pie game
dot init
you will have to initialize the module
first before you do anything and now I
will Define the width
and the height of our window
actually a thousand pixels
comma 600 pixels and I will Define this
inside the initial section
and then to create a blank window which
I'm going to call as WN you will need to
type in pi game Dot
display
dot set underscore mode
and inside this you will have to kind of
given a single element which contains
the dimensions so I will Define another
Tuple inside this and then type in the
width
command height
like that so what this does is it
creates a blank IDM window with a width
has thousand pixels and the height has
600 pixels
so when you talk about the pi game
window in particular let's say that this
is a dummy window for our pygen window
the initial position is always going to
be here so this position will be called
as 0 comma zero but then as we progress
towards the right the x-axis is going to
increase and then when you progress
towards the downside the y-axis is going
to increase so this position will be the
maximum in terms of the y coordinate so
when you go towards the right this is
going to be thousand comma zero because
this is the maximum point of the x-axis
and as you go down this will be zero
comma 600
and then as you move towards the right
this is going to be the maximum point
that is 1000 comma 600. this is really
useful when we want to define the
positions of the objects that we want to
draw on the screen and also the
scoreboard on the top and left hand side
and on the top right hand side as well
now what I will do is create a main game
Loop this is where all of our animations
the visual effects and the Motion
Graphics will be happening and they will
be happening constantly to the updated
latest statements so to do this I will
Define a while loop and rather than
keeping this as true like this I will
Define a variable known as one and then
make this true and give it over here so
that if at some point we want to break
out of the game or just toaster but no
we can just simply make one as false so
inside this main game Loop what I will
be doing first is I will type in for I
in High game
dot event
dot get
so the way I like to explain this
statement is whatever you do inside a pi
game window let's say you're trying to
press the quit button to exit the window
Pi game will identify this Spy game will
know that you have pressed the quit
button but then it won't know what to do
after that so what it does is let's say
if the user has pressed the quit button
then iGame will store this in
pygame.event and what we're doing here
is getting all of those events one by
one and storing Sni like for example not
only the quit button let's say the user
is trying to press the up Arrow key to
move the paddle up or the down arrow key
to move the pedal down all of them all
of the events are stored in eigen events
and we're getting them one by one and
storing it in I so that we can check for
a particular event and take specific
actions accordingly like for example
when the user press the quit button then
we will have to instruct the code to
just close the window and break out of
the loop or another example is just
let's say if the user presses the up
Arrow key then we have to make sure that
we instruct the code to just move the
paddle up when the up Arrow key is
pressed
I will check in for the quit type so if
I DOT type
is equal to equal to Pi game
not quit
this will check for if the user has
pressed the quit button and it will
return true if they have pressed the
quit button and if this returns true
then we can simply make run as false
now before running this program let me
just create another section and call
this main Loop
now let's run our code and see
here you see a blank buy game and now it
says High game window and then when you
try to close the window
it closes nice also there is one more
thing that I want to mention
is that you see here that it says eigen
window you can just change this to
whatever you want
by just typing in pi game
dot display dot set
underscore caption and inside this you
can type in whatever you want I will
type in wrong but that's it like that
now when you run this code
you see there is pong but better over
here nice
now let's get started with drawing the
objects and to draw anything inside the
pi game window it will generally use the
statement known as High game
dots draw and then the shape that you
want to draw in our case first we will
draw the ball which will be Circle and
inside this first you will have to
mention where are you going to draw the
circle which will be the window and then
you will have to mention the color which
will be blue for my case
and then you will have to mention the
dimensions or the positions of where you
want to draw the ball which we will
Define later I'm just going to call it
ball X and well why
and then we will also have to mention
the radius
so we will have to Define all of this so
what I will do is create a color section
in fact
let me just do this right around here
colors and first Define the blue color
which will be in the RGB format which is
going to be 0 comma 0 comma two five
like that now I will Define another
section for the ball
and this will contain first radius
which will be 15 pixels and then the
balls x coordinate
which will be
the entire width
by 2 minus the radius
and similarly for the height
right by two
minus the radius like that
the reason why I'm doing this is
actually when you type in width by 2 the
ball's radius or the center of the ball
is just going to be placed towards the
right rather than the center of the
screen so when you type in y radius what
you see is the ball will be placed at
the exact center like we wanted to and
similarly for the height as well so this
way we keep the ball at the exact center
which is what we want to achieve
now when you run this code you should be
able to see a ball
and we don't so why do you think this is
happening well because this statement is
given to the buy game window but then it
is not being executed because this is
not updated to the latest statements so
to do this what I will do is to type in
iGame Dot display dot update so this way
the game is updated the latest
statements and it is being visually
available as well so now when you run
this code you will be able to see the
ball
nice
and then similarly for the paddles we
will type in pi game
dot draw Dot backed and inside this we
will have to mention where do we want to
draw this rectangle which will be the
window
and then the color which will be red
and then rather than just giving in the
dimensions like we did for the circle we
will have to type in a statement as Pi
game
Dot rect
and then we will have to mention the
position in terms of the x coordinate
and then the what coordinate followed by
the paddle's width and the battle side
so for the positions we will have to do
it two times one for the left and one
for the right the battles
X and then left hand side battles
white coordinate and Then followed by
the battle width which will be same for
both
Commander pedals height
I will copy the statement
and then paste it over here
and then change this to right like that
now we will have to Define each and
every single thing
so let's do this first I'm just going to
define a section for the paddles
which will ever call as paddles
dimensions
and inside this first let me just Define
the paddle's width and the height which
will be the same for both paddle bit
manifold height
I will call this 320
and 120. and then in terms of the y
coordinate both the battles are just
going to be same so first I will Define
titles y coordinate
left paddles
why
which will be equal to right spell why
which will be
the entire height
weight so minus the battle height
2.
like that and that thought for the
paddles x coordinate
but the left will be
and I will also Define simultaneously
white as well
for the left hand side it's just going
to be 100 minus the paddles width
by two
and then but for the white will be the
entire width
minus this same so I'm just going to
copy this
and then put this inside parenthesis
like this
and I will also have to define the red
color which will be
in the RGB format once again so
comma zero comma zero like that
now we should be able to see two paddles
on the screen along with the ball
we do nice
okay let's get started with the
movements and as I did before I'm just
going to start with the ball and the way
I'm going to go with this is by creating
a variable known as false velocity in
terms of the exponent as well as for the
y coordinate
like that and then keep them to be one
pixel comma one pixel so what I'm going
to do here is add this velocity
constantly to the original position of
the ball so that the position
continuously changes because we're going
to put that inside the main gate Loop
and to dehumanize this will appear as
still the ball is moving so hopefully
that makes sense when you look at the
color when you look at the output it
will make much more sense so let me just
create the movement section
and before that it will put this one
into objects
what's this one
and also I have made this so that you
can read the entire code like this
rather than having them like this I will
keep them like yeah so what I will do
now is just add in the velocity to the
original balls position so balls X will
be
um velocity X similarly dot by the Y
as well
now we haven't defined the bounces or
the collisions itself but then I want to
see if the ball is making some sort of a
movement on the screen so let's just run
a currency
okay so first we see that the ball is
moving but then it's leaving trails
rather than just moving its original
position so this can be simply corrected
with a single line of code
which I will explain in a second but
first let me just type out whatever I
want to
whenever Phil
enable
and then the black color
you find the black it's big zero or flat
zero of green and zero of blue like that
all right so here we add the initial
positions of the object and we have also
written down the statements that be used
to update the positions of the ball so
we expect the ball to kind of move like
this because we're updating the
positions and this updated position is
used by the pygen draw statement so that
it draws onto the screen in the new
positions well it's mostly true in this
case but it's mostly correct but there's
just one catch here that is each time
the new position is updated and each
time pygen.raw statement draws on the
window the new positions it doesn't
erase the already existing position so
what happens is
this
we see that the ball is being drawn onto
the screen on top of the already
existing wall position so is it a
humanized this appearances so the ball
is leading Trails so the way we correct
this is by using the window.fill
statement what this does is each time
after we start the loop or end the loop
we just fill the window with the black
color and then draw the positions once
again so that the already existing
positions are pre-raced and the ball's
new position is being drawn onto the
screen and this appears as so the ball
is moving to the human eyes so let's
have a look at that
what you see around here is the already
existing position is being erased in the
new position is being drawn each and
every single time the loop is running
now when we run this code we should not
be seeing the ball leaving trails
and yeah if the ball moves and it goes
up the screen so what I'm going to do
next is Define the bounces as to that if
the ball hits the top boundary or the
bottom boundary then we have to make
sure that the ball is bouncing and then
moving so just recall that the top
boundary right here y position over here
is going to be zero and then over here
it is going to be 600.
so first let me just reduce the velocity
a little bit to make it
0.7
and then 0.7 over here and now let's
define a section named
balls movement controls
like that
and then inside this I will use
conditions to check if the ball is
trying to go off the screen from the top
side or the bottom side so if the balls
like one is less than error equal to
zero plus the radius because we're
checking if the ball's end point is
trying to touch the top boundary rather
than the center so that's why we add in
the radius like this and then similarly
for the y coordinate in terms of the
height so if volts white coordinate is
greater than or equal to the entire
height of the window this time minus the
radius because again we're checking it
for the end point rather than the enter
if any of these conditions is true then
we just basically reverse the direction
of the fall in terms of the y coordinate
alone
like this so This Way the balls white
coordinate Direction it's just changed
but the magnitude stays the same so when
you run this code
we see that the ball bounces and it goes
off the screen which is actually what we
want so what I'm going to do next is to
check if the ball is going offset the
screen on the right hand side or the
left hand side and if it does then we
will have to reset the game and this
time layer 2 will get the serve
so this time we will have to manipulate
using the x-axis so let's just stack for
if the balls x coordinate is greater
than or equal to the entire width
minus the radius again similar reasons
then
we will have to retrieve the initial
positions
I will copy this
and then paste it here
and just change the world's velocity
the reverse Direction and do the same
for y as well
like that so this time if the ball tries
to go off of the screen then it resets
to the center and then this time layer 2
will get the serve and if the similar
thing happens to the left-hand side
player
which is
if voltex is lesser than or equal to
zero which is the initial position plus
the radius
then again we will have to retrieve the
initial position as well as that would
initial
velocity as well so I'm just going to
copy this
and paste it here now when you run this
code
we see that the ball is going to bounce
and go off the screen similar thing
happens here and then this goes on
forever nice
now let's start to make the paddles move
based on the user's given input so first
let me just Define the part of velocity
right pedal below
and then left parallel
which will be zero as of now
and then first I will check for the
user's inputs so
lfi DOT type is equal to High game
dot key down
this signifies to check if any of the
keys on the keyboard is being pressed
and it will return true based on that if
it does then we will have to check what
key is it so we will type in I dot key
will be highgram dot k underscore up
this is kind of a notation to signify
you to check if the up Arrow key is
being pressed and if it is then
white battle velocity has to go up
so we will make it to be
negative 0.9 so this way we're
subtracting the y coordinate position
from the paddle so that it goes up like
this
and then we will do that similarly for
the down arrow key as well
High game
okay underscore down
again kind of a notation to signify the
down arrow key is being pressed or not
and if it is then right paddle velocity
will be 0.9 this time we are increasing
the y coordinate so that the paddle goes
down
similarly we will do that for the left
hand side as well
if I dot key
equal to equal to and I will use the
wasd controls because that is kind of
standard annotation for the left hand
side
to Pi gan
node K underscore W to check if the
battle is trying to go up and if it is
then
left battle velocity will be negative
0.9 and then similarly
we will check if
idle key
yes buy game
dot k underscore a
actually s works
then we can make left hand side velocity
to be 0.9 like that now I will add this
to the movements
y
less equal to
right pedal velocity and then similarly
left file y
Plus
left battle velocity
now when actually there's one more thing
that I had to do to check if normal keys
are being pressed we can check
rather than using alif we will use if I
DOT type
is equal to equal to High Gain or key up
which checks if normal further keys are
being pressed or the already pressed key
has been taken off if that's the case
then we can make Auto velocity to be
zero again
velocity will be zero and then we will
do that or
a y coordinate so left-hand side battle
as well now when you run this code you
should be able to move both the paddles
with the proper control
so it moves nice and then this as well
excellent
now before getting to collisions I just
want to make sure that the paddle
doesn't go off the screen like this so
to do this let's just create a section
known as paddles movement controls and
over here what I will do is first I will
check if the paddle is trying to go
beyond the boundaries so first let's
type in for the left hand side adult
if it's greater than or equal to the
entire height minus the paddle height
then we just keep it there
equal to the entire height
minus the battle height
and similarly if it tries to go beyond
the boundaries in terms of the y
coordinate at the top side if left hand
side paddle y
is less than or equal to zero
let me just keep it there
that's battle y
will be zero now we will do this for the
right hand side by just copy pasting
this
Ctrl Z
paste this here and then change this to
right
now let's run our currency
and we see that the paddle is not going
off the screen which is exactly what we
wanted to happen
over here as well nice now let's get to
the collisions
so the idea here is just very simple if
the ball's position is somewhere within
the range of the paddle's position in
terms of the x coordinate and in terms
of the y coordinate then we just have to
make sure that the ball's Direction
reverses only in the terms of the x
coordinate
again here we are in the initial
positions and the first thing that I
want to show you is whenever you type in
left battle X or white battle X whenever
you want the first initial positions of
the battle it is always going to be on
the top left hand side which is
indicated by the small yellow circle
when you actually want to access the
initial position to the right paddle you
just type in right paddle X and here as
well the small yellow circle is
indicating that so what we want is the
Collision to happen on this face of the
paddle that is on the right hand side
face of the left-hand side paddle so
what we have to do is also adding the
paddle bit so that the position is now
on to the phase where we want whereas
when you get to White's battle we don't
actually need to do that let me just
show you here
we see that the collisions has to happen
on the left phase of this battle so we
don't need to add in the paddle width
whereas we do then the cursor is going
to move towards the right hand side
which is not actually what we want
first I just want to cut this and paste
it above movements
paste it here
and then Define collisions over here
now let's just start by checking if the
ball's X position is within the range of
the battle's X position
this shouldn't be greater than or equal
to left battle X
but then it should be less than or equal
to the left battle X Plus
the actual paddle of it
like that
then we will also have to make sure that
the ball's y position is also on the
range of the paddles y so let's add a y
should be less than or equal to
balls y
which should be less than or equal to
plus the battle type
I did not
and what we will do is first we will
keep the ball at The Retreat phase or
the edge of the paddle itself and then
reverse the direction
so balls X
will be
left battle X
Mr battle whipped
and then we reverse the direction in
turn to the x button
into equal to
negative one we will do that for the
right hand side battle as well but
before that let me just run our code and
see
if the Collision is actually working for
the left hand side
it does nice so we just have to do that
for the right hand side battle as well
we will do that
I'll just copy this
and paste it here
then change this to right first
and then we won't need this anymore
because we're just keeping it at the
left face of the right hand side battle
so we just keep it as it is and then
reverse the direction now when you run
our code and see
we see that both the paddles are making
collisions properly and
we have Reflections nice
so this is creative angles so so far
we've kept the Velocity in terms of x to
be equal to Velocity Y and we would
always end up with the direction like
this each and every single time the game
resets and this is indicated by this
green line so the ball would make a
movement Direction like this and then it
resets to the center now this time let's
say I'm going to add in another
statement let's say I'm going to keep
velocity in terms of x to be in two
times the velocity Y and then we would
get an angle like this so the ball would
move in this direction now again I will
add in another statement and this time I
will keep velocity y to mean two times
velocity X and we will end up with an
angle like this which is again indicated
by this green line now the ball would
make the movement like this
and what I'm going to do is also do this
for the top side as well so that in
total we get six angles and then provide
the machine the choice to choose first
the ball should move on the top side or
should it move on the bottom side and
then change the respective angle of the
three choices that is provided so let's
take a look at the code implementation
okay so now we will have to import
random import condom and then I will
create two new variables
one for the direction at which the ball
should move we will randomize that with
zero and one zero signifying top and one
is going to signify a button we will do
that for the angle as well I will have
three different angles
zero will stand for y being 2 times of X
and one where X and Y are the same and
two where X is two times of Y now we
will scroll down all the way to
where we reset the game so right around
here after retrieving the initial
positions of the ball
we will now have to randomize where the
ball will move either the top side or
the bottom side so first let's create a
variable inside this and use the random
Choice option
to get a random choice
of the direction
and similarly we will do that for angle
as well
random.choice
of angle like that
now I will first check for the direction
if Direction equal to zero that means
that the ball will have to move top side
so we have to keep the Velocity in terms
of y coordinate to be negative but first
I will also check for the angle if angle
equals a zero
then that means Y is going to be 2 times
of x
so ball velocity y
current of all velocity X
will be negative 1.4
comma 0.7
followed by if angle equal to one
then we can have both of them to be same
well velocity X
will be negative 0.7 comma 0.7 like that
and if the angle is equal to 2
then ball velocity y comma ball velocity
X
will be of the software negative 0.7
comma 1.4 like that
now I will copy this and do that for the
downward direction as well where
Direction equals one
I will paste it right around here
I'm going to make direction to be one
and then take off all of the negative
signs
like that and now since we randomized
the direction in terms of top side or
bottom side we won't need this a more
whereas we will have to have ball
velocity X
cleaned it off
and for the right hand side if the ball
goes out of bounds from the left hand
side so the ball has to move towards the
right hand side so we can just copy this
once again right round from here
all the way down here
Ctrl Z
then I will paste it here
and we don't need to have in this
statement because we want the bulbs
directly to move towards the right hand
side rather than changing the direction
towards the left so now when we run our
code we should get three different
creative angles each time the ball is
reset so we run our currency
let me see the first angle we see the
second one and we see the third really
nice
I just want to show you the prompts of
how the new element that we're trying to
add into the game should look like it
says active which means that it has to
be manually activated by the user and it
says once activated the next condition
of the ball onto the paddle should
reflect the ball back at 3.5 times the
original speed as a surprise to the
opponent this means that this is kind of
a smash element and this has to be
activated manually by the user
this will be the logic that we will be
implementing for the gadget so let's say
that this is a given position and as
soon as the pole comes to the bottom
boundary we just use the statement to
reflect the Bolt's Direction and it
moves up so what happens here is the
ball approaches towards the battle and
as soon as it comes in contact with the
paddle we other than just multiplying it
with negative one we multiply it with
negative 3.5 this way this negative sign
ensures that the ball is reflected back
but then this 3.5 ensures that the ball
is moving very fast and it's a price the
openness so that will be the logic that
we will be working on for this gadget
let's see how it works
so for the gadgets first I will move
outside the main game Loop and create a
section for the gadgets
like that
also make sure to have some space here
and over here what we can do is first I
will create the activation variable to
check if the gadget is being activated
or not so left underscore Gadget
will be equal to right underscore Gadget
which by default is turned off
if the gadget is turned on then this
will become one for the respectives
now I will create a variable for the
maximum amount of gadgets so that will
be left Gadget remaining
which will be equal to the right
Gadget remaining
which will be 5 or my case you can have
how much ever maximum Gadget as you wish
now we will have to trigger the
activation as an if a button is pressed
then we will have to make sure that the
gadget is being activated so to do this
first it will go to I dot key faction
over here first I will do for the arrows
area if I dot key
equals or equal to Pi game
dot right
that is the right arrow key and we will
also have to make sure that the gadget
remaining is
greater than zero right the adjective
remaining should be greater than zero
then we can have the right Gadget
to be activated
equal to one like that and
I will move down
or the left hand side paddle
if I dot key
is equal to
High game
dot KD
that is a right arrow for the asdw keys
then and also I have to make sure that
enough scattered remaining is greater
than one left yard
remaining is greater than zero
then we can make the left schedule to be
one that is the activated case
equals one like that now I will scroll
down and create a new section right
around
here
Gadgets in action
so we will first Define what the gadgets
have to do it's just the same thing if
the ball is within the range of the
battle then rather than just reversing
the direction alone we will reverse the
direction in 3.5 times the original
speed so I will copy this
and first check if left Gadget is
activated or not if left Gadget is equal
to one
then I will paste this
and then rather than having this as
negative one I will have this to be
negative 3.5
and now I will make the left Gadget
to be zero
and also
left Gadget remaining minus equals one
because we have to negate one each time
our Gadget is being used so now we will
do that for the right hand side Gadget
as well
if right Gadget
and just scroll down a little bit equal
to one
and then we can copy this
and paste it right around here
like that
and have this to be negative 3.5
followed by right Gadget making it to be
zero once again
and we're doing this to make sure that
once the reflection has happened once
the bowl has been returned in 3.5 times
the original speed the gadget is no
longer effective they will have to
activate it once again to make the same
movement once again
so rights Gadget remaining will again be
negative equals one we will have to
negate one so that the number of
remaining gadgets is reduced each and
every time they use the gadgets so now
let's run our code and see if the gadget
is working
this is the original reflection speed
now I've activated the gadget
and it does really nice
also the prompt says that as a slight
indication to the opponent once the
gadget is activated there should be a
small circle inside the battle
so to do this it's just very very simple
we will go down to the objects section
and over here
let me just do this and
check if left Gadget is first activated
or not left Gadget equals one
then we will have to draw something else
I N Dot
Raw
but Circle
and window
white color we haven't defined white we
will do that and then we will have to
keep the ball within the rectangle that
we created so we will do that by typing
in left battle X
plus 10
and similarly in terms of Y as well left
Arrow y
plus 10 like that
followed by the radius it's just
radius is going to be let's say four it
has to be a small circle
and we will do that for the right hand
side paddle as well if right Gadget is
activated that means it should be one
then Pi game dot draw in fact let's just
copy this
control Z
paste it here
and then change this to be
right battle X and over here as well
like that now we had to define the white
colors I'm just going to go into the
colors section
and over here I will Define for white
white will be
255 comma two five five comma two five
five
we will now run our currency if a slight
indication circle is being drawn onto
the paddle if the gadget is activated
and we do we do for the right hand side
battle now I'll do this for the left
hand side as well
yep it does work and once the Collision
happens it goes off nice so the prompt
for the flash Gadget says that active
which again means that has to be
manually activated by the user and it
says immediately after activation the
pattern should teleport itself towards
the ball's current position in terms of
the y coordinate
the logic for the flash element is just
very very simple let's take this for
example the ball is approaching
downwards as well as the battle but in
some case if the battle is unable to
reach the ball and if the gadget if the
splash Gadget is being activated then we
simply use this statement that is we
just change the battle's y coordinate to
Bear the balls while coordinate is and
the battle teleports itself to the balls
but what in it like this so let's take a
look at the code implementation and see
if this works
now for the second Gadget we will check
for the input from the user first
Right Round Here
if I dot key
equal to
highgame dot left this time
okay left the left Arrow key
and also make sure that right Gadget
remaining is greater than zero
then we make white Gadget
72.
which signifies for the second Gadget we
will do that over here as well if idle
key
equal to
highgame dot a
okay and let's go a like that
and we will also have to make sure that
the left Gadget remaining
is greater than zero Omega bar
then left Gadget
will be two in this case now we will go
down to the gadgets and action section
and over here we will check if
left Gadget
two
then we just make the left battle y
that is the position of the paddle in
terms of the y coordinate
to be the ball's y coordinate itself
like that and now we will have to make
the left Gadget to be zero
and also
subtract a number
from the number of gadgets remaining we
will do that for the right hand side
paddle as well
if right
we won't use Alice
Alice
right Gadget
equal to two
then make white paddle y
to be equal to the both y coordinate
like that make right Gadget to be zero
and also
subtract a number from the number of
gadgets remaining like that
let's run a code and see if the other
Gadget is working as well when we press
the left Arrow key and it does really
nice we will do that for the left hand
side paddle as well and it works
beautifully now when you look at the
prompt for the cloning Gadget you see
that it's active and once activated the
next Collision of the ball onto the
paddle should clunk the ball to confuse
the opponent one being original and the
other one being duplicate
this is going to be the logic that we
will be putting into this gadget so if
we take a look back we have defined the
reflection physics for the ball we have
also defined the condition physics for
the wall and we've also made sure that
the movements are working properly so
what I'm going to do is just draw
another Circle for the entire game and
then put this on top of the ball such
that it's just hidden behind it and I'm
going to put each and every single
metric the reflection the collisions and
the movements exactly to be the same as
for the original ball so that when the
gadget is actually put into action let's
say that the ball is moving in this
direction so both the circles it's just
simultaneously going to move in this
direction and right as it approaches the
paddle let's say in this direction it
just does this both goes in different
direction in terms of the y coordinate
this is just by changing the dummy balls
Direction in terms of the y coordinate
and then they both Go in different
directions one is going to be original
and the other one is going to be
duplicate meaning that the meaning that
if the original ball comes in contact
with the other paddle then the
reflections happen normally whereas if
the player 2 is confused and goes for
the zombie ball then it will do nothing
and then the game resets giving player
one the point that's the whole point
having this gadget let's take a look at
the code implementation of how this
works
so we will have to make changes to all
of the sections that is on your screen
and we will start with from the balls
section I'm just going to copy this
and then paste it here this is called
the creation of the dummy ball X so I'm
just going to have namibal access the
prefix dummy all X
we'll do that over here as well
and over here as well nice now we will
need to scroll down all the way to balls
movement controls and over here the
logic is just going to be the same just
going to copy the first if condition
and then paste it
just change the variable name to dummy
over here as well
and then we will reverse the direction
or the meatball velocity like that and
then inside this first we will have to
retrieve the positions for the dummy
ball as well so I'm just going to copy
this and paste this here change the
variable names to dummy
and over here as well
and then right inside the if condition I
will
actually copy this one as well and then
paste it chase the names
like that and change their names to
dummy ball velocity
we will do that over here as well
similarity equal to
this one
so after completing all of those you
will also have to remember that we have
to change the direction in terms of the
dummy ball as well so I'm just going to
paste this and change the name to dummy
like that
and now we will have to do the same
thing over here as well let's retrieve
the positions by copying it
and paste it here and then change the
names
dummy
and then get inside the if condition to
change the ball velocities
we will do that over here as well copy
this
next we will have to get to the paddles
collisions and inside the latest if that
is the condition is just going to be the
same rather than just changing the
direction of the normal ball we're also
going to change the direction of the
dummy ball as well with the same
condition so we're not going to declare
that for the dummy ball I'm just going
to change the direction directly
if the original ball is in the contact
of the paddles then this wall the dummy
ball also should reverse the direction
that's the logic we will have we will
also have to do that over here but
before that I will also retrieve the
positions to keep that at the edge of
the pedals
hey stairs
and then make this to becoming ball
like that we will have to do it we will
also have to do it over here as well
now before getting to the gadgets and
action section all that we have defined
so far inside the gadgets section is for
the gadget pair one we will also have to
do this for the second Gadget but before
that we will have to ask the user on
which gadgets should they start with so
what I'm going to do is before doing
anything with pi game I will first
declare the gadget Band by default is
going to be one and then I will ask for
the input of the user
input enter your choice
enter your choice
will get a parent
and then what we will do is actually
first let me just convert this to ins
then what we will do is we will first
check for the condition if CH equal to
one
and we keep Gadget pair to V1
that is CH equal to two
then we will keep Gadget out E2
now that's decided we will in fact
scroll down to get it in action section
and inside this what we will do is first
copy all of this
right around here and press down
because what we will do is
first check for the gadget Banner if
yeah
equal to one then we will execute all of
the commands that inside this
and if
Gadget pad
equal to two
then you will have to then we will have
to start with the cloning section that
is ball cloning and paddle cloning so
what we will do is as defined earlier
we're just going to change the dummy
balls Direction when the gadget is
actually activated so what we will do is
go to
the left battles collisions and we will
copy this
and paste it here
now rather than just changing the
direction in terms of the x coordinate
what we will do is we will also change
the direction in terms of the y
coordinate so that one ball will move
towards the bottom side or the swap side
and the other ball will move to the
exact opposite intensity y coordinate so
when we type in dummy ball
velocity y
and then multiply that
into equal to minus one
I forgot to mention one thing
the let Gadget should be one
then we will execute this condition so
we'll put this in tab
and then we will make lift Gadget to be
zero
and then Gadget remaining
left Gadget remaining negative equal to
one
maybe we'll Simon Says stated that for
the right hand side Gadget as well
um tab if right Gadget
equals one
we will copy from the right Gadget right
paddle collisions
paste it here
and what we will do is again
change the dummy Bolt's Direction in
terms of the white coordinate as well
instead of equal to minus one
and then make right Gadget to make a
zero
and then also
make a white Gadget remaining
negative equals one and we will get to
movements and also add this for the
normal as well
tell me about X Plus equal to
dummy ball velocity X followed by
that mean for y
plus two dummy ball velocity y
you will also have to draw the circle so
what we will do is I will copy this
and then paste it over here maybe
actually I will paste it over here
dummy World section
paste it here change this to dummy ball
X
change the name over here as well
change this to like this
we also come down to Gadgets in action
section also make sure that the dummy
ball is reflected back at 3.5 times the
original speed as well because even
though this comes under the gadget bar
one we have to make sure that both the
circles are making simultaneous movement
so what I will do is
just
keep the dummy ball velocity X maybe
negative
3.5 like that now we'll do this for the
right Gadget as well
get a statement
and then keep this to me dummy
like that
and now let's run our currency
so first we will have to enter our
Gadget pair Choice I'm just going to
keep this too because we're testing
let me press enter
we see originally that the ball is going
in the same direction and then we're not
seeing the second ball but then when you
activate the gadget like this you see
two walls like that very nice we will
check that for the other side Gadget as
well
if I can hit
yeah it's working very good and so here
is the prompt of the final Gadget it
again has to be manually activated by
the user and it says immediately after
activation the paddle should clone
itself both being original and thus
providing more area control
logic is again just drawing the second
paddle and on top of the original paddle
and then make movements normally and
simultaneously and whenever the gadget
is activated we separate them by let's
say 200 pixels by just adding into 100
pixels and then it provides us that
battle cloning effect so let's take a
look at the code implementation of how
this works as well
again we will have to make changes to
the necessary sections and we will start
with the pedals Dimensions by creating
the Second Battle and this time I'm
going to have a prefix of second rather
than having this to be dummy because
this time the pedal is actually not
being dummy like the ball so first I
will copy this and paste it here
and then add the prefix second
and right round here as well
like that and it will also
create velocities for the
second paddle what I will do is copy
paste this and
have second over here
now we will get to the input section and
over here we will have to check if the
barrel key is being pressed and if it is
then not only we should move the
original pedal we will also have to move
the Second Battle as well which is on
top of the original battle
Second Battle
well
geek40 0.9 negative zero nine like that
you will do that over here as well
second right velocity
be closer 0.9 if the down arrow key is
being pressed we will do that over here
as well
now we should get to paddles movement
which is right round here and we just
simply copy paste this this is just
making sure that the paddle doesn't go
off the screen either by the top side or
the bottom side we will have to do that
for the Second Battle as well so I'm
just going to paste this and add the
prefix second
next we will have to get to paddles
collisions and over here we can't just
simply copy paste the conditions like
this let me explain why
so the reason why we can't just copy
paste the collisions for the second
paddle is because let's say if the ball
is approaching towards the paddle and
remember that there is two paddles one
in bulb of the other so if we Define
collisions for them both at the same
time then there is going to be two
collisions happening at the first
Collision the ball will change the
direction this way but since there is
another arrow on top of this the
direction is again going to change and
anyways the ball is just going to go off
the screen which is not actually what we
want and the way we correct this is by
first checking if the positions of these
two paddles are not equal let's say if
they are separated like this that is if
the gadget is in action then if the ball
is approaching towards top atlest the
primary paddle then Collision would
happen normally and then if we Define
for the secondary paddle as well then
again a collision is going to happen
normally so that's the logic that we
have to work on let's look at how that
works
and hence we will have to first Define a
condition to check if the Second Battle
velocity actually in Second Battle X or
the Second Battle Y is equal to
the original paddle
which is the left paddle Y and if it is
then we should only Define collisions
while one of these I'm just going to
keep the original pedal like that
and we will have to do that if
you check
if they both are not equal
not a closer
left paddle y
then we will first have to Define for
this so we'll copy this
and then paste it here and then it will
also paste it once again because we will
have to also do that for the Second
Battle as well
displays it here and then add the prefix
second
so now if the ball comes in contact with
either of the paddles then it gets
simply reflected back which is actually
what we want now we will do that for the
right hand side paddle as well let's
check if the coordinates are the same if
second white adult y
equals it
like out of Y
then we can just have this as it is I'm
going to stab and copy this
get tritrons here and check if they both
are not equal
rights battle away second right out of Y
not equal to
white throttle why
let me just paste it
come over here
and paste it once again
now we can add the prefix second
and then you get to the gadgets and
accent section and scroll down to second
pair and check if
the left Gadget is equal to two that is
the second Gadget if it is being
activated
so if
actually others
less Gadget equal to two
then we keep the second
left battle y
to be
left battle why
Plus 200.
now this will lead to the paddles
learning itself to the human eye and
then we can just simply make left Gadget
to be zero
and also subtracts one from the gadgets
remaining
left guys remaining minus equal to one
we will do that for the right hand side
as well
and this right
Gadget equal to two
and then we just make the second right
paddle
y to me
write about a y
let's do 100.
like that and make white Gadget to be
zero
also subtract one
from the right Gadget remaining
like that now we will get to the
movements as well and over here we will
Define for the Second Battle
seconds left paddle apply plus equal to
second left parallel well followed by a
second
right battle y
plus equals a
seconds
right I don't know like that
you will have to draw that over here so
I will create another section
battle
and I will copy all the battles this and
paste it over here
and then just change
this to the prefix seconds
also I forgot to mention one thing when
you get to the input section
that is
here we also have to make sure that when
no key is being pressed
then the second velocity is that is the
second part of velocity should also be
zero
or by second right spiral velocity
v0 as well now let's run on code and see
if the second paddle is appearing on the
screen when we activate the gadget so
first let's type in two
and we see that now we have only one
paddle but when you press the left Arrow
key or the a key then the left the
second Gadget will be activated and if
second Gadget is activated then we
shouldn't see the paddle cloning like
that we do nice
so right around here when you activate
the gadget like this and if the game
resets originally we just want the game
to reset with the paddles as well but
that is not happening in this case
because we haven't defined it to we will
have to make sure that once the game
resets the paddles also reset to its
original position so the way we did it
is by going to the
volts movement control section over here
once the game resets every time what we
do is add in two lines over here that is
the second
left battle y will be let's battle y
that is a resetting back to the original
position
we will do that for the right hand side
paddle as well second right about y will
be
White's battle y like that
and then we will do that for the second
if as well that is if the ball goes at
the screen on the left hand side
then again second
rights battle why will we write about
why
and we will do that for the left hand
side battle second
that's about a y equal to left paddle y
now we should have everything according
to our needs let's draw a currency
type in two
over here we'll activate my Gadget right
round now
click here as well
trying to miss actually I can't miss
and yeah over here we see that
once the game resets the battle also
reset which is actually what we want I
will show it to you right here as well
yep we get it all right all that is left
down is just the scoreboard and the end
screen so in order to calculate the
score first we'll get to the initial
section and then I will create two new
variables layer one
come on actually
both will start off at zero so player
two will also be equal to zero player
one will be referring to the left hand
side player and player 2 will be
referring to the right hand side layer
and we scroll down all the way to boss
movement controls and over here we see
that the ball is going off the screen by
right hand side so we're here player one
will get a point
plus equal to one because since the ball
is going off of the screen from the
right hand side the left hand side
player will get the point now if you
scroll down to the other if condition
over here ball goes up the screen from
left hand side so player two will get a
point this time okay so that's equal to
one so that's how you calculate score
now how do we write this on the window
so I will scroll all the way down
and over here before getting to the
object section right around here
after movements I will create a new
section in the scoreboard
so first we will need to get a font
through which we have to write on the
window we want to leave Pi game
dot system font the font Dot
sys font like that
and then for Simplicity I will just use
calibery and then we also have to
mention the size which again for
Simplicity I will be keeping that as two
I will be keeping that as 32.
now I will create another variable score
and then I will type in font dot render
this is just basically instructing the
program to use the font that we just
imported and and generate the text that
I'm just going to type in which will be
player
one
then do this
plus SDR I'm just going to make the
string
of player one
true and while we also have to mention
the color
I will just keep white authenticity
now we have everything ready we just
have to write this onto our window how
do we do this we just type in
window.blit
we mentioned what we had to write in
which is the score and then you also
have to mention the positions so in
terms of the x coordinate I will first
keep this to be 25 and in y as well I'm
just going to keep this 25.
now I will just copy this
and then paste this once again over here
and then now change this to player 2.
over here as well
and then change the x coordinate to
around about say 825 and keep y-axis as
it is now we will quickly run a currency
get the power to be two
and yes it works we see player one
scores one and play two score is one as
well nice now we will also have to do
that to mention the number of gadgets
remaining so what I will do is first
let's just name this to be score one
and score two
and what I will do is I will create
another new variable Gadget
left one
and similarly actually just
kept change it over here as well
it's here
well it can be font start render
let's type in gadget left
a space
Plus
can make the Str and
Lefty as it remaining
true
followed by the color which I will add
this as white
like that
and we will type in made out of Blitz
Gadget left one
the positions this time will be 25
comma 65 we are just off placing it a
little bit in terms of the y coordinate
I will just copy this
and paste it here maintenance to be
Gadget left two
and then make this
right Gadget remaining and this to be
so now let's just run a code and see if
gadgets is being shown
let's type in two
and we see the number of gadgets left
this Phi and the scoreboard is also
ticking nice
okay so all that is left out now is the
end screen so let's scroll all the way
down and create the section over here
and inside this first we will create the
winning font which is just the same
thing
but then I will keep the size to be 100
and then now I will check if either of
the players are greater than three
points this is the winning cap this is
the winning limit you can have the you
can have whatever number you want but in
just for Simplicity to show you that the
end screen element is actually working
I'm just going to keep it at three so
that the end screen will be so that the
game will end faster
greater than or equal to three and what
we do first is fill the window by using
the window.fill statement with the black
color
and then we will type in the end screen
variable to be font dot render actually
winning a font dot render
and then say player one
one
keep the anteriorist to be true
and then mention the color I will keep
this to be white which we already find
and then blip this onto our window
window.blit
end screen
mention the coordinates I'm just going
to keep it to be 200 in terms of X and
so 15 in terms of Y let's say and see if
this is working I will also do this for
the play itself as well just copy this
paste it right around here
then change this to player two
that
now let's run that code and see if it's
working
enter the guided choice to be one
go over here
right as player 2 gets three points it
displays that player to one again really
nice
and here it is the modified Bongo now if
you made it up to this point of the
video then I just want to say thank you
for sticking with me now I again do
recommend to check our Channel now
there's just tons more in there so
that's it bye-bye hope you see that